[Music]
Julia
Julia what are you doing oh well I've
been binging old Fixer-Upper episodes
and I decided this ugly backsplash
simply has to go oh and careful don't
trip over that tasteful mid-century
lighting fixture oh and don't touch
those walls they're freshly painted Uber
neutral beige okay I'm not gonna lie I'm
kind of loving the whole Airbnb field
but uh how much is it gonna cost oh
don't worry babe it'll all end up back
in our pockets at the end of the day
investing in equity am I right
maybe I could even become a house
flipper okay I think this has gone a
little too far not all remodels end up
like they do on TV and how about we just
do a little bit of digging to see what's
really worth the time and effort
[Music]
Home Improvement is Big Business
globally the industry is worth about 333
billion dollars and it's expected to
grow to over 500 billion by 2028. the
pandemic actually facilitated this
growth that kitchen you used to forego
using in order to eat out became your
new sourdough baking Zone staring at
that ugly wall color all day long
finally became too much to bear and with
dining out and travel taking up less of
our budgets home projects happily
gobbled up our free dollars working on
your living space has also become
entertainment I remember watching the OG
home improvement show This Old House on
PBS as a kid with my parents and these
days there are entire networks devoted
to property Improvement like HGTV and
Magnolia designers and developers like
chip and Joanna Gaines and the property
brothers are literal celebrities and
before and after footage doesn't just
show up on the TV anymore home
renovations and DIY influencers are also
dominating our so feeds no I get it
seeing before and after pictures is like
visual ASMR but if you've ever attempted
a home project Beyond just replacing a
broken appliance you know it can get
eye-wateringly expensive in fact for
about the last decade Home Improvement
costs have been steadily climbing above
and beyond National Baseline inflation
covid and the ensuing spike in prices
obviously made it a lot worse but the
average cost versus value ratio hasn't
been looking pretty since around 2014.
so what sort of improvements really give
you the most bang for your buck and if
you're a renter is there anything you
can do to improve your place without
breaking the bank okay Julia want to
play a little Home Improvement game oh
yeah I got this what do you think is the
most profitable home improvement you can
make oh
oh no wait bathroom
final answer and sorry topping the list
with the most bang for your buck is
garage door replacement in 2021 people
on average spend about four grand to
replace a garage door and upon resale
got about 3 700 back that means you're
losing seven cents on every dollar
invested which is about the best you can
expect these days the Journal of light
construction has been tracking National
and Regional costs for Home Improvement
projects for 35 years they then compare
the cost to the value of the Improvement
upon the sale of the house obviously Roi
can depend on your location an
improvement in one area of the country
might not be as valuable as in another
turns out according to their study
kitchen remodeling my favorite comes in
at number three in terms of
profitability with 71 cents on the
dollar and bathroom redos are even worse
usually between 50 and 60 cents of the
top 12 projects that give the high
highest Roi 11 of them are actually
exterior focused projects like upgrading
siding and adding veneer accents which
actually makes sense people tend to
customize indoor spaces more to their
own liking and personal taste which
might not translate to the next buyer
but when it comes to outside projects
you're forced to consider what strangers
might be thinking as they walk or drive
by it also might surprise you that
things actually get worse the more money
you put in many studies looking at
remodeling numbers tend to break up
projects by budget level on one side you
have minor cosmetic improvements and on
the other you have major ones like
knocking down walls and putting in
upscale features according to remodeling
magazine the average cost of a minor
kitchen facelift will run you about 14
773 dollars if you turn that around and
sold that home a year later you'd get
about 87 percent of that back but if you
went for the mid-range Duo over and
spent close to forty thousand dollars
that would go down to about eighty
percent back want to splurge and spend
eighty thousand dollars you might only
get close to half back of what you put
in also remember that these numbers
aren't assuming that you're paying
interest or taking out debt to do it
however not all is financially lost if
you want to make some improvements to
your space here are a few tricks that
can help you remain as in the black as
possible first off you're already
engaging with the most incredible tool
for Home Improvement YouTube learning
how to cut down on labor costs is a huge
way to save skills like demoing painting
tiling and refinishing surfaces can all
be done relatively easily by amateurs if
you're looking to cut energy costs with
energy efficient upgrades like replacing
a water heater HVAC unit or even solar
panels you can take advantage of some
pretty sweet tax credits due to the
inflation reduction act that can really
help your bottom line but what about
renters I mean they make up about 36
percent of the American population
believe it or not there's a lot of cool
stuff that you can do to your place as a
renter that doesn't mean you'll be
lining your landlord's Pockets most
leases will allow you to change out
things like lighting fixtures faucets
shower heads even changing out drawer
handle Hardware can be easy and make a
big difference just make sure you keep
the originals handy for when it's time
to move but once you've bought them
yourself they're yours to keep changing
the walls and flooring can make a huge
difference in a space but don't be
tempted to rip up that carpet or
linoleum or paint those rented walls
just yet instead invest in things like
rugs that can be easily moved from one
place to another there are also lots of
really cool stick and peel solutions for
things like walls and backsplashes and
even bathroom floors to cover up those
unsightly patterns okay Jules how you
feeling
I suppose I can acknowledge that
replacing this backsplash is more like
replacing a pair of pants I don't really
like anymore than investing in my IRA
exactly most experts agree home
renovations aren't really Investments
who would want to invest in something
that has a close to guaranteed negative
rate of return but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't attempt to do them just
approach it like any other lifestyle
upgrade you're considering don't take
out debt ink from your emergency fund or
touch your Investments to do it research
a little Sweat Equity and strategic
splurges will keep you sitting
financially pretty through those before
and after pictures
and that's our two cents
before you go we want to tell you about
a new slate of documentary series on our
sister channel PBS voices these series
cover everything from hip-hop and Tech
to the origins of sacred rituals
unconventional Community engagement and
the welcoming spaces in the lgbtq
community there's something for everyone
so if you haven't been over to PBS
voices we hope you check them out
there's a link down below
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
[Music]